alamam
[Silence]
I
in
We are
continuing in our journey our reading of
authored
by
regarding the Sunnah of the Prophet
s is a book that is
very voluminous it is a very
very it is a very Epic book and an
incredible
reference and it is probably the most
important book
that authored he authored many books
more than 70 some of them are thousands
of pages and some of them are to be
considered small
treaties
however is
unanimously been pined over and worked
on
and read and studied as kind of a
staple for all those who came
after wishing to discuss any part of the
Prophet
Sall which he touched upon in this very
important book it's a very illustrious
book
and of course it's not completely
translated into English I I did see I
met a man many years ago maybe 13 or 14
years ago in New York
and he was
translating
now in
riy originally from India and Pakistan
daram in
riy had
translated the summary of
so there's a summary there's a number of
of authors that came after that
summarized
but one of those summaries which is very
well known was summarized by a
mamed and this
book is the book that chose to
translate so about 13 or 14 years ago in
New York I met a man from phe
originally and he was translating Z he
wasn't translating the a bridged version
he was translating all of Zed and
which in itself is kind of a
questionable Venture the reason for that
being that there are many things in z
which do
not they are not pertinent
to the English reader there are a lot of
things in that are not pertinent or even
understandable to someone who's not in
the field of or or or Linguistics and
grammar and things like
that would speak on all of these issues
and and so rightfully so Z was
summarized it was
Abridged I had seen at that point that
he had I believe translated one volume
of the
five I didn't see him again after that
I'm not sure where he reached with that
but even if he did translate the whole
thing it is possible that a translation
that would do more bad than good
in the sense that it would cause a lot
of confusion to someone who's reading in
the English language so the scholars of
Islam
they write books for a certain type
of person to
learn so for instance if you look at a
book written by a
scholar such as even the early books if
you look at a book
Al
for not the explanation of Muslim
another book
in that's that's good for all students
of it's good for anyone who wants to
learn the basis and the foundations of
the Sha it's fine but there are other
books that aren't really made for that
they weren't designed for that they were
designed for people in a particular
field to read and I think it's that
with any science
really so when you take that and you
give it to someone who is not equipped
to handle that kind of you know the
terminology and the jargon and
subtleties that a person specializing in
that field would understand a person
unacquainted with that field would
grossly
misunderstand this is why
Scholars summarize and a bridge books
that's why why they have
this they do these
things so that the general masses can
benefit from the core points of the book
without the technicalities and so it's
important for us to trust our
scholars in that so for
instance he wrote his book
which is referred to
as this
book this book that wrote that is
referred to
as he wrote it for his generation for
people studying the science of Hadith
for people who are memorizing Hadith he
wrote it as a staple as a basis a
foundation
for that science the general masses of
people who are unacquainted with that
science are not going to be as benefited
by it in its original form and this is
why Scholars
summarized that's why Scholars
summarized Muslim they summarized J
and many of these books were summarized
and pined over and Abridged in order
that it could be more accessible to
the general
reader it's important for us to
understand that and to honor that
because in any field if you start at the
top you're going to fall really really
hard meaning you're going to make a lot
of mistakes in trying to understand
especially from a book A book doesn't
correct your understanding it was
written that
and right it needs it needs a key
to be understood
so the best book that you could get to
my knowledge of the many different
summarizations of
Z is
the The Abridged version of Z
authored
by
Muhammed and this book is referred to as
a bridged
Z or summarized Z by it's printed for
many years by in RI and it's a very good
book it takes all of the core of what
intended with writing the book and makes
it into a very accessible volume we've
not been reliant on that some summary
we've added things and we've also
skipped things based on how this
class should be fashioned really so we
are continuing
in
by which is one of the
references
that used in writing his
book we are discussing the Miracles of
the prophet sallai
wasam
and
we
reached some of the
sections
where is discussing the
prophecies because the prophecies things
that will happen in the future or
prophecies things that happen in the
past but have not been
recorded these are a type of of
miracle in themselves there's no way to
know these things that in the far future
or in the distant future or even in the
near future that such and such will
happen such and such will
unfold and when a prophecy this is
that detailed and it unfolds in the way
that the prophet Sall alai wasam
described that makes it a miracle that
makes it something that we know he
received from subhanahu
waala we stopped last
week discussing the story
of we mentioned he was alive in the time
of the Prophet
s he was unable to meet him which makes
him a which is as close as a person can
be to a companion without being a
companion of the Prophet s. wasam he
mentioned that this
man will come from
Yemen and he will be a man who is very
close to Allah subhanahu wa taala and
that he achieved that nearness to Allah
by way of his obedience and dutifulness
to his
mother that has such
a such such
a strong
Dua in such a place with Allah subhanahu
waala that he made Dua that Allah heal
him of
his of leprosy that he was afflicted
with and Allah healed it and reduced it
to a small patch on his foot the size of
a the size of a
silver
coin we mentioned that this happened and
this occurred in the time of Omar and
the prophet Sall wasam said this to
Omar I said to him a man will come this
is his description and sure enough this
man came in the time of om and om was
actively searching for him every time
new people would come in
from from Yemen on their way to a
sham or on their way
toq they would stop in Medina Omar would
ask and inquire
if is amongst them until one day he
was another Miracle another another
prophecy
[Silence]
for
e
[Silence]
is
the
[Silence]
was
another Prophecy of the
Prophet is that there will always remain
a group of people at any given time
throughout the Muslim
umah this group collectively will be
upon the truth they will be upon the
right way they will be upon the pure
Sunnah of the prophet Prophet s. wasam
they are pure of innovation they are
pure of inoculation they are pure of any
of these things which
afflict individuals and groups of the
Muslims in
general now what's meant by a
group from my
narrations this are often
Twisted by people who have agendas if
you have an
agenda if I if I have an agenda and I
wish to bring followers to follow me
unconditionally what better way than
to articulate to my followers that
the prophet himself s. wasam spoke about
me and this group there a very powerful
way to control people and so this
narration has been taken out of
context by many groups who have used it
incorrectly so the narration goes this
narration is in bukari and Muslim the
narration goes that the prophet s. wasam
said there will always remain amongst my
umah a group who are upon the clear
truth they are clear they are present
they are accessible they are upon the
truth they are upon the right way the
path of Allah and his messenger the path
of Allah subhanahu wa taala behind the
messenger of Allah s. wasam on his
Trail they are purified of innovation
they are purified of and collectively
the truth is found in them they will
remain as such Until the End of Time
none who forsakes
them and none who takes them as enemies
will be able to truly harm them until
the command until the will of Allah
comes to pass meaning the day of
judgment this is the narration now
sometimes this narration has been
Twisted by some
groups that use this narration to try to
claim make claim to
it and what goes through a person's mind
is there will always be a group among my
Nation meaning a group of people
physically together in one
place and that's not necessarily what
the narration means what's meant is
dispersed amongst the Muslims amongst
the entire Muslim
amongst them in groups or
individuals the true pure religion of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala will be found
in
them
collectively not every one of them has
all of it in them no
collectively collectively all of the
Quran and Sunnah all of their meanings
and adherence to their laws will be
found in this group collectively it
doesn't have to mean a group of people
in one particular place which is how it
was twisted often you know some of these
groups they come up and and they use
this narration kind of to say hey
we're that group because you see we're
together and they claim that they are
upon the truth Etc that is not
necessarily what the narration
means the prophecy here is not just that
the umah of the Prophet Sall alai was
Will Thrive will not just survive but it
will Thrive it will flourish it will
expand across the
Earth as the prophet
s. said so ELO quently this religion
will reach wherever day and night have
reached on this
Earth not only that that will
happen that the Muslims will remain
relevant they will remain prevalent
until the end of time but amongst them
there will always
be a people upon the clear and pure
unadulterated guidance of Allah
subhanahu wa taala
unadulterated guidance of the Sunnah of
the prophet sallai
[Silence]
wasam
s
[Silence]
sub
for
[Silence]
a
Quran
[Silence]
was
de
another
prophecy that the prophet
s tells us
of is
that a time will come when people will
be very
numerous but those who truly
follow will be very
few now there's a couple of
meanings to this narration that the
scholars of Islam have
that the scholars of Islam have
explained it
with and that is that it could be meant
that the people will become numerous
meaning that people on Earth in general
Muslim and non-muslim they will become
very
numerous we see this is happening people
are you know population global
population is at an alltime
rise but those
who are
an meaning those who
are Victors and vanguards of the
truth those who are devoted
followers of the word of Allah subhanahu
waala that they will become fewer and
fewer this is one meaning another
meaning mentioned by the scholars is
that what is meant by an
here is the Muslims in general the
Muslims will become very very
numerous but those who are
truly
unadulterated and truly on the pure
truth and their eyes are fixated their
hearts are filled with the Hereafter as
the early generations of the Muslims
were that these individuals become less
and less over
time and this
both these both of these meanings are
very well known and both of them have
other narrations that bolster them and
support them or it could mean that
people will come into Islam and those
who are the ansar meaning the people of
Medina who first believed in the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam their
descendants will become more
scarce these are three meanings which
are mentioned all of them are correct in
the way that they unfolded and it could
be said that this narration means
something
different based on the time and place to
which it is applied this is possible as
well this idea that at the end of time
this prophecy that The Closer
Humanity grinds towards the day of
judgment the closer Allah's command and
for is to blow into the
horn the closer we get to that day
closer we get to that time the more
fewer the fewer and
fewer people upon the truth and people
fixated on the Hereafter will
become and as we know that at the End of
Time the prophet sallallah alai wasam
tells us that one thing that will ail
the Muslim and of course course it's not
just the Muslims
non-muslims of course those who are not
even Muslim and don't have any of the
guidance of Allah or his messenger or
have very little of it they will be more
prone to these to these ills and to
this decadence that will kind of erode
Humanity's heart near the end of time
but one of those things will be
superficiality that people will become
very good at saying and not very good at
doing speaking me and and that can be
with anything with the Quran for
instance those who memorize the Quran
are very
numerous those who follow and adhere
strictly to the
Quran to where the majority of their
efforts and time and the majority of
their thoughts and so forth revolve
around the book of
those people will be much
fewer
right and so often times we conflate and
confuse the people of knowledge in the
Quran and Sunnah with the people of
facts of the Quran and Sunnah those who
you know learn the Quran they're able to
recite it very well those who memorize
the Sunnah of the Prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam they're very well
researched and well read and learn it
that is just one
step this now demands action it demands
adherence and the Hallmark of that
adherence is that a man or woman who is
truly devoted to the
Hereafter their
deep more
complicated
ills will be dealt with right you
youve got kind of levels of purifying a
person's soul you've got the most
basic level is what telling the truth
not murdering people not stealing not
committing adultery not worshiping
Idols right then you have other higher
levels that more fine-tune
Soul such as another level of watching
what you say things that are not major
sins they're sins but they're not major
sins or they're sins but they're not
sins that hurt other people necessarily
outright there are sins that sins of
arrogance
and you
know poor temperament and these types of
things there is another level of
adherence this kind of fine-tuning the
higher we go with that the less and less
people there are at that level that
excellence and this reaches a point
where something that
is permissible for those on lower levels
or Haram for those on those higher
levels right person becomes a we look at
this we see for instance prophethood the
prophet
s things that are permissible for us to
do
are not permissible for him to do things
that are preferable for us to do are
obligatory upon the prophet sallallahu
alh
wasallam right these things become more
and more intense as a person rises in
their esteem with Allah subhanahu wa
taala so near the end of time this will
occur and this all has come to pass as
the prophet sallallah wasam
[Silence]
mentioned
for
[Silence]
another prophecy is that
the the ansar here
meaning as opposed to the MU
the companions are divided into two
major parts you have the M those who
migrated to Medina and the ansar those
who are native to Medina and receive the
migrants that the
ansar after the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam passing and after the
great times of the which are 30 years
the time of Abu bakar and Ali after
these times
there will start to be a lot of
selfishness with regards to those in
power there will be a lot of tyranny and
there will be a lot of
misallocation of public wealth and the
ANS will bear the brunt of this they
will bear the brunt of this meaning they
will not be taken care of and part of
this is because
the prophet Sall wasam mentioned that it
will remain in the people of qur and it
is something for the M of qur and this
was even
mentioned
in the story of when the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam passed away
and Abu Bakr was appointed Omar and Abu
Bakr and the others of the companions
mentioned this to the ansar and they
said
you know the ANS cannot be the prophet s
alam's successor it has to be from the M
the ANS were always meant to be help
helpers and AIDS to the
muajin so after this time of great
Justice the time of the 30-year
successorship of the Prophet sallallah
alai wasam the era of Abu Bakr the era
of Omar the era of the era of Ali to an
extent the era of
alassan IB Ali that after this 30 years
is
concluded people will be placed as
leaders over the companions many of them
will not be Companions and they will be
very tyrannical and this is something
that came to pass and the prophet s.
wasam commanded that that the ansar be
patient and that they endure this
that they endure this Injustice and
mistreatment for them to reap their
reward and the
Hereafter at the Lake of the
prophet
[Silence]
for
subhah
[Silence]
for
in
[Silence]
Al
allb